c'est un petit clip vidéo qui donne la
pêche sont en avance et quand carine
geoffroy est la fondatrice de
l'association sihem coprod qui a mis en
ligne la vidéo aux missionnaires de
charme où elle avait participé à un
premier clip sur la musique de pharrell
williams à pie ix a pour mission de
promouvoir le bon vivre à cherbourg
et le succès est au rendez vous 132
milles vues sur youtube et des centaines
de lettres de cherbourgeois sont envoyés
en soutien à l'association pour lancer
un deuxième puits ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'il y avait une effervescence et
un engouement très rapide par rapport à
ce projet là
l'objectif étant de vraiment pour
mouvoir la ville de cherbourg ne l'ont
fait qu'il fait bon vivre
c'est vraiment une ville très attractive
et très attachante
un tournage où l'on retrouve les places
emblématiques de la ville mais surtout
où l'on ressent une bonne ambiance
communicative comme nous les scripts
pierre marion chef étoilé à cherbourg
elles nous ont juste dit amusez vous
quoi à la cause musulmane à musique bas
mais je me sens mieux a lancé moi je
passe les combats ça a été très quelque
chose de très spontané est très sympa
été rejouée ça va pas être les histoires
commencent
il n'y a pas de scénario fait enfin
voilà quoi c'était vraiment quelque
chose
un cheikh bou comme vous ne l'avez
peut-être jamais vu et dont la vidéo
récolte déjà plus de 9000 eu en trois
jours
je ne suis
est ce que tu es